[toilet flushing]
boing!
YOU LOOK
STRAIGHT AHEAD, SIR.
DON'T LET THAT SCARE YOU.
THAT IS THE BANE
OF OUR EXISTENCE,
THE BLACK PENIS.
AND, REMEMBER, NO MATTER
HOW BIG HIS (BLEEP) IS,
AT LEAST YOU RUN
THE GOD DAMN WORLD.
[laughs]
YUCK.
AH, IT STINKS.
IT STINKS.
DON'T YOU WORRY.
MUST'VE DRANK A 40 OUNCE.
[laughs]
I'M A PIXIE.
OH.
CAN YOU SEE ME?
YEAH, I CAN SEE YOU.
WELL, LISTEN, THIS IS AN "A"
AND "B" CONVERSATION,
SO WHY DON'T YOU JUST "C"
YOUR WAY OUT OF IT.
SAW THAT ON ONE OF
YOUR NEGRO SHOWS, MARTIN.
[laughs]
AND WHY DON'T YOU
SEE THESE NUTS?
[yelling]
THEERE'S YOUR PISS.
[screams]
IT BURNS!
MY EYES!
MY DICKIES!
[screaming]
YOU MIGHT HAVE WON
THIS TIME, (BLEEP).
I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU SAW ME.
I'M GONNA TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR TAX RETURN.
YOU MUST'VE MADE
A LOT OF MONEY
IF YOU CAN SEE ME.
WOOGIE BOOGIE!